it was just after midday in the occupied
west bank city of nablus when israeli
special forces along with domestic
security agency shin bet carried out the
raid
according to witnesses undercover troops
used a taxi with palestinian license
plates pulled up next to a car and
opened fire spraying it with bullets in
broad daylight
after the israeli forces left people
gathered to see what happened no one
suspected the vehicles were carrying the
israeli soldiers simply because of the
palestinian number plates the israeli
soldiers continued to fire for a minute
they fired more than 80 bullets and the
young palestinian men were killed on the
spot
the palestinian men were accused of
involvement in recent attacks against
israeli soldiers and civilians the
troops were filmed taking weapons from
the vehicle before they left the scene
a case of extrajudicial killings
according to the palestinian authority
that requires an international
investigation family members gathered
outside the morgue to share their
sadness and anger along with members of
the community
my son has been hunted by the israelis
for months the israeli intelligence
called for my children and threatened
them for my son to give himself in
israel's defense minister benny gantz
commended his security forces for the
operation prime minister naftali bennett
says there is no immunity for terrorists
i am really sad not only for this crime
but for the entire situation the
palestinian people have been in for
decades
we are used to these crimes but we must
act in response
i am really sad we are filled with anger
but no one is lending us a helping hand
the al-aqsa martyrs brigade the armed
wing of the fatah party says it will
retaliate
three more young men caught up in a
seemingly never-ending cycle of violence
andrew chappelle al jazeera